a year ago carlos carrasco was struck by
leukemia really didn't know if we would
see him again and yet he worked his tail
off to get back to get ready
i mean locked him up with a beautiful
off-speed pitch kind of a slurvey yeah a
little slider right there back door
and he struck him out nice
all three breaking balls and solaire
took the first two went waving at the
third
jose ramirez two for seven in the series
with a double and a run batted in
at the end of the back weekly squid to
third
and mejia threw it wide pulled him off
the bag and with some fancy foot
jose ramirez avoided the tag at first
and he is safe on one of the weirdest
looking plays you'll ever see
he was saying before the game about
bolanos we'll see how many pitches he
throws in the first inning
and he goes with a slow breaking ball to
get francisco lindor
and they're two down romeo reyes comes
to the plate
there's a line drive into right field of
base hit ramirez scores carlos santana
stops at third
and the indians strike first with a two
out rbi hit from ron mill reyes
boy what a nice job of hitting right
there that's a a knock that this offense
really needed with two outs now domingo
santana
and he flares one into right field
that's going to get down that's going to
split the outfielder santana will score
gray is on his way to third he is going
to be safe but domingo santana is out
trying to stretch that into a double
phillips has got a terrific arm so you
got to know who is in the outfield and
he picked it and that's a nice play by
modesty to pick the baseball and put the
tag on and now the count goes full
to franco
throwing out in this boy that was a
really nice off-speed pitch by cookie
his third strikeout on the afternoon
[Applause]
they've got differing numbers the royals
call it eight straight the enemies call
him nine
he'll let them flip the point
fourth strikeout jose ramirez he reached
on an error that really opened it up for
cleveland in the first yeah
they feel that it gives a better spin
with it smash in the right and it ain't
up cordero it'll go to the wall
hernandez is off to the races mike
starbaugh will wave him all the way
around and score ramirez dashing for
third he's in there safely and the
indians lead is now three to nothing
lindor shoots it fair down the third
base line ramirez can trot home and
score
four nothing cleveland lindor into
second base with an rbi double well
that's exactly what uh lindor needed he
needed to go the other way that ball was
out over the play did a nice job of
staying on it
he took a
call third strike on that pitch in the
first inning
let's hit in the air to left field
slicing away from reyes and it's going
to bounce off the wall and alberto
monteci has his first hit of the year
he'll be at second base with one out
dangerous hitter at the plate royal
single season home run numbers jorge
soler
nice pitching against solaire for the
second time today orozco strikes it off
that gives him a half dozen k's in the
game here's salvi with a runner at
second and two down
salvi was on that pitch and he's going
to drop it into center field
monday comes around third and zimmer's
throw is late
and the royals are on the board as salvi
drives into second of the year two on
one out in the home half of the fourth
is jose ramirez who has reached twice in
the scored two runs today
jose hammers it deep right field back is
cordero he's out of room it's out of
here and the indians have their first
home run of the season a three run shot
by
jose ramirez here in inning number four
and the indians have blown the lid off
this baby and now lead it seven to one
he struck out two in the first inning
that went a long way to help him
as mejia is called out seven things
the royals have two on with two out now
the batter's whipped murrayfield the 1-0
pitch
swung outlined sharply to the left
that's a base hit
franco comes storming around third he
will score and merrifield comes through
that's why he is so difficult to pitch
to
you make a mistake and he is ready for
you
carlos carrasco he'll start the sixth
inning just over 70 pitches on the day
swung out of his hey struck him out that
gives him eight k's on the afternoon
salvador perez goes waving at a slider
and now cookie is one strikeout shy of
hitting
double figures here today now the 1-2 to
gordon
swing and a miss he struck him out the
tag will be applied well he'll flip it
down to first he goes the long way and
carresco strikes out the side
[Music]
here is ramirez who has
reached three times
ramirez rocks one a deep left field down
the line it goes and it is go on a home
run for ramirez
[Music]
wow that was right down the chuck the
only question would it stay fair and
indeed it did
bronco made a nice play
first base to end the last inning now he
leads off the seventh
there it is go go go ball on an 02 pitch
and simmer oh he dropped it
[Applause]
or at least it went off of his glove but
it's down for a lead off double bring up
domingo santana two for two couple of
singles to walk in an rbi
oh santana smacks it deep left field it
is off the top of the fence
carlos santana on his way to third and
domingo will go into second with a
double what what an afternoon he has had
on face all four times
bradley zimmer a chance to tack on some
more for cleveland
has been on twice and scored a run pops
this one up
left field
tagging carlos is coming home here's the
throw and it is not in time santana
beats the play with a head first slide
so they test the arm of ryan mcbroom and
carlos santana makes it a 9-2
lead cam hill makes his uh debut there's
another guy with an electric arm
first ball swing ground ball in the hole
backhanded
with a one-hot throw to santana and they
gotta want to play no doubt man he made
that look easy
went down to one knee come up and made a
beautiful throw
now the 2-2
swung on him as he flew by him upstairs
to end the ball game
that's a pretty good exclamation point
for a sunday afternoon at progressive
field as
take the finale and win the series
against kansas city 9-2 is the final
here today